hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome chess puzzle now we don't really
show a lot of chess puzzles on this
channel but when we do it it's well a
really entertaining one this one really
caught my attention so I decided the
shirt would you guys and I'm not going
to make the same mistake I did in the
previous puzzle I'm actually gonna tell
you what the point of the puzzle is this
time and it will also be in the title
and that way you know as the end of the
year is near we are gonna have another
subscribers video the 2020 subscribers
video but we are going to discuss that a
bit more after we check out the puzzle
so this is the puzzle it's white to play
and win and it's white actually delivers
checkmate in ten moves so unmoved and
white delivers mate so there you have it
you can share it with your friends at
the bar in the library they're really
gonna enjoy this one and well you can
either pause the video or try to solve
it now or you can just you know print
screen it save it for later
or you know you can just do whatever you
you want with it
but for those of you that I will now
show you the solution and it's it's
really an interesting one the title is a
bit of a hint so yeah of course you you
might have realized that by now but for
those who don't want to know the
solution you know skip fast-forward if
you were just interested into in hearing
the announcement of the subscribers
video to 2020 but for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the solution
is well obviously black has only one
legal move black can only play d3 and
white can play a lot of different moves
wife can move the King Y can move this
pawn this pawn this one but basically
you have to be very careful not to stay
on made black that's the point of the
puzzle so for example if you bring a
queen enter game black will make a move
play d3 and whatever move you make its
stalemate there is no way to prolong the
game any move you make on the board
whether you push the pawn or you put the
Queen anywhere it's still gonna be
stalemate like any move and it's
stalemate so that obviously will not
work so what you have to do and this is
why the title of the video is a bit of a
hint you have to bring a knight into the
game
so black will waste the only move black
has which is d3 and now you have to give
black more moves and you do that by
sacrificing
the night so nice the b6 you give black
the only legal move which is C capture
sin b6 and now you start to promote your
C pawn so c7 black will start pushing
the beep on which is the only legal move
now you bring another Knight into the
game so once black you know it depletes
all of the remaining moves before now
you have to give him more legal moves
which is Knight to d6 and now you you if
you bring a queen enter game it will not
work you will still run out of legal
moves so here you will just capture it
with black and now white continues to
Queen the e pawn with d5 the only legal
move for black we have e8 again with a
knight again if you bring the Queen into
the game black we'll just play d4 and
you will not be able to checkmate black
any move you make will be stalemate or
now okay now you could prolong the game
with something like quinta III give
black a move but then it's actually
black who's winning after after he gets
a quintet again because you still have
legal moves as white
so after this d5 move you bring another
Knight into the game with v8 knight then
after the last legal move is wasted by
black now you play Knight to f6 you give
black another legal move and after the
final light is captured
now you will use the last night the
checkmate the black King with f5 and now
again okay now you can bring your Queen
into the game and after something like
capture story for deliver checkmate but
this will be making eleven you have to
deliver mate in in ten so after f5 you
just bring the last night into the game
and this is why it's a nightmare of a
puzzle I thought you guys enjoy that as
well now the black king is checkmated
because the King covers the g7 square
and the pawn covers the g6 the g6 square
so that's very interesting is the only
solution I've seen similar solutions to
has seen similar puzzles to this one but
I've never seen this particular one so I
don't know the origin of the puzzle if
any of you do know the origin of the
puzzle do share in the in the comments
below so we can all increase our
knowledge and I was actually made aware
of this puzzle by a gentleman named
Justin he tagged me on Twitter and said
whites to move in
so that's where I got the puzzle from so
thank you mr. Justin and as you can see
I also used his profile photo from
Twitter for the thumbnail of the video
as like I said I don't know the origin
of the puzzle I have to give credit to
someone and he made me aware of the
puzzle so I thought why not so that's it
for the puzzle I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've made your friends at the
bar in the library very happy now on to
the announcements so like I said two
thousand and twenty subscribers video
for those of you who have been following
the channel for quite some time you
might know what I'm talking about and if
you don't I will put two links in the
description below one will be the
subscribers video 2018 and the other one
will be the subscribers video 2019 now
as the channel grew the subscriber video
2018 is some 12 minutes long and the
subscribers video 2012 19 is over 40
minutes long so I expect the subscribers
video 2020 to be like over an hour long
since a lot more of you are following
the channel and a lot more of you might
be interested now I don't want to bore
you with the technicalities we're gonna
discuss that a bit more but basically
what I need you to do and what all of
you have been doing for the past two
years so thank you incredibly a lot for
that is that you have to teach someone
the basics of chess like you don't even
have to teach them just get them a
little bit interested in chess and that
that way we can all promote chess even
further so basically if you've if you're
doing that you know throughout the year
that's awesome but this is this is again
your your chance to be the ambassador of
chess for if you're not doing it for for
a whole year maybe just for this one day
so pick one person like maybe your
sister or your or your father your
brother your girlfriend you know a
grandma a total complete stranger or
your friends at the bar in the library
and teach them a chess as a teaching him
some chess or tell them something
interesting about chess tell them an ice
chest story told them about Paul Morphy
told them about the home Stein it's
about a man you'll ask about Capablanca
try to get them interested in chess you
know have a beer really it doesn't
really matter it just has to have
something to do with the chest take a
photo of that moment where you are
teaching them in chess and send them I
send that photo to me
an email that will be provided in the
description below like first if first
thing in the description will be the two
links to the subscriber videos and then
the third link will be the email where
you can send your photo I do which we
will use to create the subscriber video
2020 now you can also send us a video
make it a short video since I do expect
a lot of people to to send it and I
don't know if it will be one video like
I said the subscribers video 2019 was
over 40 minutes long and that's just
that's just a lot so I'm thinking either
either we're gonna make shorter
sequences but if if too many of you send
us send the photos then it's gonna be
really hard to make it well I'm not
gonna make it myself I'm gonna give it
to a professional video editor because
my video editing skills are non-existent
basically I don't know if you realize
but I actually don't edit my videos so
we're maybe gonna make either too short
to shorter subscriber videos 2020 which
will be released throughout the year or
maybe I mean I like subscribers video
2018 was like 12 minutes long so I think
that's the that's the perfect length for
something like that so if if it will be
enough to make a subscribers video maybe
2020 maybe an hour long so maybe we're
gonna make six shorter ten minutes
videos and then which can be published
throughout the entire year I don't know
I still haven't decided on it since well
I'm really not the the most qualified
person to decide on matters like these
so if you have a an idea you know please
do share in the comments I would be I
will more than welcome it so that being
said do check out the subscriber video
in the link in the description below the
first thing you will see and the third
third thing you will see is the email
you can use to send us your your photos
your videos
and you can also attach a message you
don't make it too long since you know we
have to make room for everyone but
basically that's it that's what I wanted
the same a bit of a different video than
usual but I do hope you enjoyed it whoo
I do hope you enjoyed the puzzle and I
do hope as many of you as possible
send us
some very enjoyable photos messages
videos and that you also will will be
the ambassador of chess for 2020 so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day I
would like to thank Charles and Adam
Decker for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
video serum think'll for watching and I
will see you soon with some more
interesting content hopefully and
continuing the Grantchester finals and
you know the battle for a third place so
once again thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day